[Music]
you got him that's kind of it like the
reason it's just just candy you can eat
those [ __ ] however you want oh
well he go look at I do like a good
sentinel battery yeah just so you know
Andrey these donations all going to
Meals on Wheels not directly to me
you can pay and I'm sort of it they
imagine giving 500 all this witty ego am
I know I know what any girl oh no no you
are not an easy role think I am no
you're absolutely not no 100% I know
what an eager look no shame - you just
love you but I think I count this one
also you know you girls have the they
have like black hair and they have the
wild browser that I would do that if I
could but I don't know how they do it oh
I also think it's a girl who just makes
money off the internet which technically
you could say that I do
that means Lawrence Larry but it's not
donations no you guys anyway I think you
guys might be more Eero boys worry boys
-
got Lawrence you do great it turns out
you are not doing great
back off of them let us do the access
thing to mixing two you can't mix two
white clothes that's crazy - why cause
what is that oh this white has three
manky buses I think and it's not a good
time one nightmare did you see what they
throw at me I don't even know what
[ __ ] killed me
I'm gonna die oh you [ __ ] do it at
brew screen brew screen everybody Bruce
is not the right choice this is not the
right choice is the right choice - - dad
I'm trying that's not the right choice
you've got it no you're doing good
you're doing or can go well unless good
now I did it
wait I did it yes my god is done pros
[Music]
whoa we shot me in the back row by the
Sun there's a shot be shot
what if it's funs over there
yeah what Oh Edith yes yes Laura get in
you know great oh my god is this your
doing wheat looking great I know
Oh oh my god no no you did so good I'm
not gonna do any way any of that good
stuff how long do we have nightmare left
cool yeah okay it's [ __ ] up I I feel
like blood shot plus super shotgun nut
that's the that's the combo not a one
shot most medium demons oh come on I had
that [ __ ] yeah I got six six help uh-oh
Lawrence you're up Ilana I missed my all
my shot yeah - off the stage come on you
[ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] got it brew
screen I've never seen anyone have [ __ ]
so hard as you have it right now you
have I don't see half the screen because
your shoulders covering it but I don't
care I know you [ __ ] got it dog there
is a lot of ammo and health packs down
oh no that was good I thought you died
but actually we were killing someone you
don't care oh my god why didn't he show
up now also why did he jump three time
is it alone murder aren't you though do
you put almost all right ultraviolets
time we just went off what
let me eat you ha ha ha
I thought I would have him because there
was ultraviolence but I didn't Allah
know I know
yeah I'm aware I thought I you know I
thought I'd be fine um but I maybe he
hit me and then I wasn't climbing yes
what oh my gosh see the [ __ ] game is
[ __ ] that is happening right now perfect
level you know that every time that you
quit and you don't get mad or whatever
because I don't remember the exact quote
you know Bruce this guy ooh baby oh my
gosh that's hot Bruce we also got a
weapon point if you want to spend that
oh you want to we love a good weapon
point here big burst right there you
don't have to kill any of them do you
think burst they won't attack you I want
to kill them but whatever man classic
where screen go to the green do what
you're gonna do green green Hey then
I'll call him Bruce Grayson everybody
Bruce I'm not very lucky Bruce Lee go
green oh no that's gonna be leave it
back for Bruce nobody remembers it's not
very rich no stay in the green Bruce
MacGyver's I don't have it holy [ __ ]
that that buddy's hard there's gonna be
four bad [ __ ] off very cool I'm gonna
take these socks off their [ __ ]
soaked in their coldest [ __ ] boy got
[ __ ] wet socks huh
no probably got hurt help if it alright
so
yeah uh-huh [ __ ] guys man second most
you and for some reason Lords I agree
with you I assumed you'd have the most
gun I know I've been havin well you've
been drinking hard I didi trust you've
been drinking hard you've been drinking
hard for the stream in that that's that
is admirable yeah that is admirable yeah
booth I think I caught that up too don't
waste the flaming voices so what do you
mean by that
the guys who have like fire coming out
of them yeah can be used as bombs on em
yeah they will never bitter really never
explode on you so don't waste them
I definitely that's it well I see you're
saying okay yeah leave them so [ __ ]
they'll just sit you know what no good
god you could shoot them and it was good
but if you didn't benefit
they're right there but on fire what if
you shot them
you just need to eat just someone I
guess eat any most all that part can't
run through that middle if you need some
help this is something so help you stand
there no charity picked it up Oh Bruce
got to it oh my god holy [ __ ] good
advice Alana boss asked me good advice
sang cruisin I don't know I really
frustrated I remember this game very
well the reason what oh what a graphic
memory you did these fights like 18
times and no it's not that many it's not
that many you just got that game revenge
okay you're in saluton the grand test of
a lot of not being in eat girls that she
remembers exactly yeah and I'm wearing a
lodge t-shirt okay so we're good about
calling this the last rotation all right
all right last rotation yeah here we go
do this here let's err I said all right
how was it
hyaaah yeah eat up yet and you got the
armor dad no you don't tentacles not
today
[ __ ] don't you find that attractive
though no all the things that dudes have
made big Raunak
are you are you too [ __ ] cool
and then you [ __ ] sit your ass down
there jump on that thing baby oh you
know what you gonna do now you gotta
flush that boy yes laughs yeah this
fight is where we are done I think this
is a up to this point the hottest fight
again this is only ultra violence yeah
this fight sucks them nice chainsaw all
right Allah you're up that's it what did
I say you've got it Alana ultraviolence
it's nothing we've been playing on
nightmare the entire [ __ ] just die
already
why can I eat you yes how many shots can
you take there we go he's dead
or on something see the Goosen do them
you get stuck that's it
this game just ends you know you got you
good you good you have so much helping
so that we worry about China's best
whatever this is going on all night
boom Ellen blood punch bro [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
off Bert Bert buddy
you got it there are only bitch-ass
[ __ ] enemies left for not except for
that wasn't meant to bus on that one
snake oh you you I am Allah Oh Bruce
green Oh Bruce great oh [ __ ] I'm trying
to change thought I didn't have it
oh that's it that's all good
we've done it that's it bye everyone
have a good night stay safe watch your
hands please stay